le cri du coeur de gabriel boulianne
tremblay a été entendu par plus de 200
libraires qui lui remettent leur grand
prix dans la catégorie roman tech
énormément parce que c'était une longue
aventure c'est sûrement là ces quinze
années de l'écriture mais à saint siméon
gabriel boulianne tremblay s'est sentie
féminine dès l'âge de 4 ans la fille
d'elle-même est en partie son histoire
celle d'une femme trans c'est en fait
l'histoire est une petite fille trans
qui ignore qu'elle est transféré dans le
québec rural des années 90 je suis allé
vraiment écrire la petite gabrielle qui
est que j'ai été
l'adolescente que j'ai été je suis allée
m'adresser à cette file
puis après ça je me suis dit il faut
écrire avec le choeur avec les tripes
dans ce récit immersif l'autrice
n'hésite pas à raconter qu'elle a déjà
été agressé c'était ma volonté aussi
d'écrire là-dessus pour me libérer aussi
de certains trauma quoiqu'il y en encore
serre est imprimé en nous pour des
libraires du québec la fille d'elle-même
et un moment important dans l'histoire
de la littérature québécoise et j'ai
adoré c'est un livre même si c'est une
histoire d'une enfant france j'ai trouvé
que c'était un récit universel dans
lequel on peut se reconnaître même si on
n'a pas vécu ce cas le véhicule aussi
comédienne gabrielle boulianne tremblay
a joué notamment dans le film ceux qui
font les révolutions à moitié n'ont fait
que se creuser un tombeau cette
militante pour la communauté lgbt qu
plus espère que son oeuvre contribuera à
changer certaines mentalités je pense
pas qu'il ya dix ans ce moment là aurait
eu cet accueil le ya même des gens qui
n'étaient pas
pour ce livre qui était réfractaire à le
lire et qui ont fait le pari de se
lancer dans cette aventure là et qui en
sont sortis grandis alors pour moi c'est
une grande récompense
avec ce prix des libraires et déjà près
de 6000 exemplaires vendus pour la fille
d'elle-même la suite est déjà en cours
d'écriture ici louis philippe ouimet
radio canada montréal